how inflation affects americans watch
this
the thousand dollar car loan payment
higher prices interest rates push up
monthly costs you know what new record
we broke last month in the month of june
according to wall street journal
the average new car that was sold last
month the payment was 686.
is it just me
or when i saw that
that to me sounded ludicrous
i i bought a ford focus my payment when
i bought from galpin ford on roscoe and
sepulveda my payment was 228 when i
bought a ford focus the average car
payment is 668 686 today so 686 if you
live in a state like illinois or if you
live in a state like new york or
california you're paying
roughly a third in taxes upwards of 57
give or take depending on where your
income is let's just say a third of your
income goes towards taxes if you add
taxes on top of 686 because that's after
tax money the average payment's a
thousand dollar payment pre-tax money
okay that's a thousand dollars and right
now wall street journal is saying hey
the way we're going right now thousand
dollar car payment is going to be very
normal
thousand dollar car payment they say the
mercedes we're talking about by the way
this is not a bmw 7 series this is the
average so ask yourself how many people
you know that have regular jobs can
afford a thousand dollar car payment
that's the direction we're going so now
let's continue
inflation in real estate market but we
gotta look at different cities where is
the
biggest growth and biggest increase in
the last two years taking place these
are the current largest real estate
bubbles within cities
showing mortgage payment and property
tax on how much it's increased in two
years meaning if you were paying a 2 000
a month for your mortgage and property
tax times 12 months you were paying 24
000 per year in 2020 how much has it
increased to 2022 ready let's go through
these you know some of these top cities
austin texas in 2020
the average payment per year was 23 593
today
six
45
eight you tell me how many people can
afford ninety three and a half percent
hike in two years
let me say that one more time how many
people can't afford ninety three and a
half percent hike if the average person
makes seventy thousand dollars that that
person's average income in austin
increased from 93 to 140 000
how can the average person afford to go
from 23 000 a year to 45. now watch this
number two boise idaho 18 200 to 33 000
per year
boise idaho 85 percent
new northport florida
16 4 to 30 thousand dollars 83 cape
coral florida 14k to 26k 83
you got phoenix arizona 16k to 29k 83
increase in two years folks this is not
a decade this is not two decades this is
24 months okay
ogden utah nineteen thousand dollars
roughly to thirty four thousand dollars
eighty 81 percent you got tampa florida
13k to 23k 77 percent provo utah 21 000
per year to 36 000 per year 75
salt lake city 22 000 to 38 000
rally north carolina 16 and a half
to twenty eight thousand seven hundred
dollars seventy three percent spokane
washington 17k to 29.5 73
lakeland florida's 11k to 19 000
knoxville tennessee 11th out to 19th
house san diego california from 35
roughly 3 grand a month
to 59
000
that's 5 000 a month 70 increase in
carolina
fourteen thousand dollars to twenty four
thousand dollars
seventy percent how many people can
afford
for their payment to increase by seventy
percent you tell me
low income middle income how many now
you may be watching this because you're
somebody that follows the content you're
a validator and you may be doing very
good for yourself and you say pat this
doesn't really affect me totally get it
but let me tell you something as a guy
that's an employer and hires a lot of
different people
we need to protect our middle income
family these are the working class that
go to work every single day they have
wives they have husbands they have kids
they have mortgage payments they have
car payments we have to take care of
them you can't constantly increase what
they're doing right now say nah it's
okay but i'm rich who cares about them
no we have to be concerned about them
this is hurting america a big percentage
of americans are being affected by this
let me continue so now
how commodity prices have increased this
is a part that jamie dimon talks about a
lot because jamie diamond's got three
things that he's concerned about we'll
talk about that in a minute this is one
of them prices from december 2019
to today aluminum 1789. let me just show
this side first watch this aluminum
1789 per ton
to 24.35 corn 388 to 590. wheat 559 to
806. crude oil
61.
202. wait to see what jamie dimon thinks
this is going to go to by the way
gasoline buck 70 325
natural gas 215
to
728
someone has to pay for that i'm
consulting the transportation company
guy last month he says pat
how do i talk to my customers saying i'm
no longer making money because my gas
bill has increased so much
that i've lost my profits i said you got
to talk to your customers because they
know this is happening he says i'm
afraid to have that conversation i said
if you don't you're going out of
business he had the conversation with
someone they were all upset but the
customers some of them were like you
know we got to shop elsewhere
and they went to shop elsewhere they're
like shoot everybody else is having to
pay the same price let's figure out a
way to make it work
everybody has to increase prices you
feel it i feel it everybody feels it so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
you